STATES.
CNN'S TOM FOREMAN TAKES A CLOSER
LOOK AT THIS DISTURBING REPORT.
>> FOR AMERICA'S LARGEST
PROTESTANT DENOMINATION, THE
REPORT IS A BLISTERING TAKEDOWN
OF TOP CHURCH LEADERS SAYING
THEY ROUTINELY MET ACCUSATION OF
SEXUAL ABUSE WITH RESISTANCE,
STONEWALLING AND EVEN OUTRIGHT
HOSTILITY.
AMONG THE SURVIVORS NAMED,
CHRISTA BROWN, WHO SAYS SHE WAS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY A MINISTER
MORE THAN 30 TIMES.
SHE HAS TWEETED AT THE PARSONAGE
AFTER ONE OF WORST OF PASTOR'S
RAPES, HE PUT ME, 16 YEARS OLD,
IN SHOWER AND STOOD YELLING AT
ME TO CLEAN BETTER DOWN THERE.
I ONLY KNEW TO CRY.
HE KNEW TO DESTROY EVIDENCE.
>> THIS IS AN APOCALYPSE, AN
UNVEILING, A MELTDOWN, AND
PEOPLE ARE REELING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
NOT JUST BAPTISTS BUT ALSO THE
ENTIRE EVANGELICAL WORLD.
>> THE SBC RESPONSE TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE SURVIVOR
COMMUNITY, WE ARE GRIEVED BY THE
FINDINGS.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO DOING ALL WE
CAN TO PREVENT FUTURE INSTANCES
OF SEXUAL ABUSE IN CHURCHES.
TO IMPROVE OUR RESPONSE AND OUR
CARE, TO REMOVE REPORTING ROAD
BLOCKS.
STILL, THE REPORT SAYS AN
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE STAFF MEMBER
KEPT A LIST OF HUNDREDS OF NAMES
OF ACCUSED PEOPLE WITH TIES TO
THE CHURCH SINCE 2007.
YET SOME LEADERS WERE SO FOCUSED
ON AVOIDING LAWSUITS THEY DID
NOTHING.
ACCUSERS WERE IGNORED,
DISBELIEVED, THEIR CLAIMED
CALLED A SATANIC SCHEME, WITH NO
NOTING OR WARNING TO THEIR
CURRENT CHURCH OR CONGREGATION.
VICTIMS GROUPS HAVE LONG CALLED
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> THE CHURCH NEEDS A DAY OF
RECKONING.
A STRIPPING DOWN TO THE BASICS
OF EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAY YOU
STAND FOR.
EVERYTHING THAT YOU CLAIM TO
REPRESENT.
>> ONE SENIOR LEADER NAMED IN
THE REPORT, JOHNNY HUNT, WAS
HIMSELF ACCUSED OF SEXUALLY
ASSAULTING ANOTHER PASTOR'S WIFE
IN 2010.
HUNT'S REPLY, TO PUT IT BLUNTLY,
I VIGOROUSLY DENY THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CHARACTERIZATIONS.
I HAVE NEVER ABUSED ANYBODY.
IN LESS THAN A MONTH, THE SBC
WILL MEET FOR ITS ANNUAL
CONVENTION AND DECIDE IF THERE
WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
>> THAT WILL REQUIRE NOT JUST
BAD PEOPLE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, ALTHOUGH THAT'S
TRUE.
BUT FOR GOOD PEOPLE TO NOT LOOK
AWAY.
>> OF COURSE, THIS IS A
VALIDATION FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN RAISING ALARMS
ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS.
BUT WHEN YOU READ ALL OF THE
DETAILS OF THIS REPORT, THE
DENIALS, THE DEFLECTIONS, THE
ATTEMPTS TO DEFEND THE CLERGY
EVEN WHEN THEY WERE BELIEVED TO
BE IN THE WRONG, JAKE, YOU'RE
REALLY STRUCK BY THE NOTION THAT
EVEN IN THE CONTEXT OF BUILDING
THIS REPORT, THERE WERE SPECIFIC
WARNINGS TO CHURCH LEADERS TO
SAY, THIS LOOKS A LOT LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE CATHOLIC